yeah so in high school I actually spent
a lot of time playing around with tools
like my Dreamweaver Photoshop and I
think I would have gotten to art school
but just learning these tools was so
incredibly hard I decided to major in
computer science and so I got to
Stanford and when I started my PhD at
the time it seemed like everyone here
was working on problems in big data and
machine learning and I certainly got
swept up in that wave and I finally
settled on a dissertation topic around
how to leverage data to build better
design tools or scaffold the design
process and at the time there are all of
these amazing repositories of design
also popping up on the web like for
fonts and interior design and 3d models
and videos but where where I started was
let's treat the the web itself as a
design repository and so my dissertation
work focused on mining design on the web
at scale and allowing designers web
designers to search through these
examples to find inspiration understand
design patterns understand the space of
possible solutions and so what this
allowed us to do was build systems where
you know people could search over the
web of design so if you were a coffee
shop and you wanted to rebrand your
website you could say show me coffee
websites with maybe large photographic
backgrounds to see how people were
integrating you know photos into their
web sites similarly you might be you
know creating a mobile version of your
page and you're wondering where should
that signup form go should it go at the
top of the page or the bottom of the
page and so this is the types of systems
that I was building as part of my
dissertation work I was very fortunate
enough to be working with an amazing
team at the time and we won a few best
paper Awards on this work
we also decided at that time because
people were asking can can we use these
tools to productize it and we were able
to raise some money from andreessen
horowitz and MEA to actually go and see
if we could build this into a product
and a business but what we found was in
the market was that examples by
themselves that's not enough they
actually had just very marginal value
and so while we had a few thousand
designers using these tools that we'd
built we found that the usage of the
tools was very epochal and by that I
mean people would use these tools during
the first few days of their three-week
long design project so you know they
would be using the tools to do research
and competitive analysis but then you
know they would actually go off and
create their designs and iterate on them
and then there were they were never
coming back to the tool and so it really
felt like we were working on the wrong
problem herb Simon says everyone designs
who devices courses of action is aimed
at changing execs existing situations
into preferred ones and I think the
important word here is preferred because
my startup we were helping designers
understand the space of possible
solutions but it was only when we
started to help them understand what was
preferable that we finally saw some
traction so you know when we built these
analytics platforms that showed how
design features actually correlate with
specific you know key performance
indicators like time on site our bounce
rate that was when people started to
kind of continuously use data in the
design process and this kind of is borne
out in other domains as well people have
similar questions about how to tie
design features to performance our
preferred outcomes and so for example
you know in mobile design people might
want to know how many steps should a
checkout flow take so that they can
prevent user fatigue or if you're
creating an outfit you might want to say
how can you look smart
without looking stuffy and if you're
designing a recommendation engine and
using you know social network as data
you might say how can you uncover taste
and taste makers in the social network
so this is kind of what my research is
about these days and this is kind of
what the rest of the talk is going to be
about it's how to use data to tie design
decisions to desired outcomes so let's
start by looking at how we can do this
for the domain of mobile app design
what's the preferred outcome for a
mobile app well app designers care about
a lot of things probably the thing they
care the most is that people are able to
perform the tasks on apps that they
actually you know want them to be able
to perform or do so things like task
completion rate lower completion time
fewer usability issues building building
UIs that are accessible these are all
preferred outcomes and you know when we
say data-driven design in the space what
we usually mean is a be testing and a/b
testing is very useful for understanding
causal relationships between design
choices and key performance indicators
but at the same time it is hard to get
statistical significance so this is a
recent white paper that was released by
a company called qubit where they
actually did a meta analyses over 6,700
large e-commerce experiments and this
was mostly in the retail and travel
sectors and they found that 90% of the
experiments actually have less than 1.2
percent effect on revenue now I'm not
walking on a bee design because even a
point four percent lift for a big
company that's 15 million dollars so you
know that's real money but this is kind
of my point where a bee testing makes
sense for large companies so if you're a
Google or a Facebook and you have enough
users to run these tests you have enough
money and engineering resources to
actually build out alternatives and
deploy them this is a great way to
continuously optimize your design but
what about everyone else right what we'd
like is to have data at scale to help us
make this as decisions without having to
be Google or Facebook and for most
designers they don't have access to this
kind of data the data at their own
companies will be small and you know
while they would like to be using data
from maybe other companies to make more
informed decisions all of this data is
locked away and siloed away within each
company so the the motivation here in
this in this research direction is can
we open source usability and usage
analytics so that everyone can learn
from them so I'm going to present you
kind of one solution point in this space
and so we built a system called zipped
which stands for 0 integration
performance testing and at a high level
what it looks like is a designer can
define different tests or tasks they
want done over any Android app in the
Play Store so you can pick it Android up
and you can say do this task on this
Android app and then what zipped
actually does is it will put this test
on a crowdsource platform like
Mechanical Turk and it will ask users to
perform this task on this app it will
collect all of these multiple traces
from all these users and then it will
aggregate that data and provide people
with visualizations that will help kind
of up level design insights
so there's kind of two parts to this
project right you are two challenges
rather one challenge is you have to
actually be able to capture this data
and then the second part is like you
have to be able to efficiently aggregate
this data so let's talk about how we how
we could do the capture the capture was
actually done by a system we built
called Erica which allowed us to mine
interaction traces on Android apps as
they were being used and the the point
that I really want you guys to remember
is that this rate we wanted it to
require no modifications to an app
source code or binary so that we could
actually collect this data from apps
that you personally didn't build and so
what are you do at a fuel for what Erika
looks like and what Erika provides is a
web application for crowd workers to
interact with mobile apps streamed from
a device farm so the apps are actually
running on a device farm and a user is
using the app through a web application
that we built and while users are
interacting with an app what Erika is
doing is it's continuously capturing
three types of data in the background
first it's capturing user interaction
data so it actually knows where you
tapped on the screen all right you know
what your multi-touch gesture was it's
also collecting the screenshot so that's
the set of pixels on the screen it's
also getting anything called a UI
hierarchy which you can think of as like
the drum tree of an Android app and what
that reflects is kind of the structure
of the UI and what are all the elements
and what we do is we actually stitch all
of this data together into these user
interaction traces so we know exactly
how a user went from one screen to the
next like where did they click to go to
the next screen we also collect the
screenshots at a high enough resolution
so that we can actually capture
animation effects on playback so what
you're seeing right here is
our data being played back as video and
so you can see like we're capturing
those animation effects as well one of
the things as we collected this data
that we wanted to be cognizant about was
minimizing the capture of people's
personally identifying information so
crowd workers are using these apps we
don't want them to give away things like
their credit card information their
emails and things like that so we
provided an interface where we basically
gave people accounts to use and there
are some little technical challenges
that we had to solve here like figuring
out how to do add verification steps so
so we figured that stuff out so let's go
back so that's how capture works and
that's the type of data we collected
let's go back and now talk about how we
actually aggregate data over several
interaction traces and the key here
actually is that we're going to leverage
all of that structure we captured in it
in order to do this aggregation pretty
efficiently so for example let's say a
designer put up this task unzipped where
they wanted a crowd worker to log that
they ate a chocolate chip cookie on the
app calorie counter so let's pretend
that we went ahead and posted this
unzipped we collected user traces and
now we want to actually look at the
results so what I'm going to show you
next is kind of the dashboard we provide
designers so first of all we provide
them some aggregate metrics such as the
average time on tasks the number of
interactions that the average number of
interactions that were taken and
completion rate so for this task it
seems like everyone was able to complete
it similarly we aggregate feedback
answers to feedback questions as well so
this gives us more insight about the
users and who they are
you know have they used an Android
before have they used the app before but
this is customizable so as a designer
you can provide these feedback questions
then we provide this flow visualization
interface and let's let's look at this a
bit more closely so the goal here is to
tell people kind of in an aggregate
sense or tell designers in an aggregate
sense how people actually completed that
task and so what you see in the dark
gray is what we're calling the designers
golden trace so this is how the designer
intended someone to do the task on the
app everything else is a deviation from
that so you can tell that even though
that you know the completion rate for
this task was a hundred percent not
everyone is doing this task as
efficiently as possible and the question
might be why you can also kind of like
get a feel for the screens that people
are going through on the side and you
might notice that there's a screen that
says hey there was a problem and so this
modal has popped up right that says
there's a problem so maybe people are
experiencing some some usability issue
here where they can't get to the next
step and after you do a deep dive you
can actually see that hey it's actually
confusing on this screen because people
actually had to enter in a unit for a
chocolate chip cookie to go to the next
screen on this app and it wasn't clear
from the interface itself that you had
to do that so this is kind of the the
way zipped works and how it can be used
to get usability insights as well as
design performance insights over apps
you didn't create now let's kind of show
you a few case studies this is one of my
favorite ones that we did so we were
here we were trying to compare YouTube
music to Spotify music and we were the
tasks we wanted people to do was a
simple one we just wanted people to
create or we wanted people to add two
songs to a new playlist that they
created and what we found
with more than 35 users doing this task
was that there is a difference between
those completion rates on this task
YouTube music only 89% well I should say
89% completed the task whereas more
users completed it on Spotify yes so
we're measuring great question
there's a few ways to measuring
completion one is self report and then
another one was answer based so you
might have people do a task and produce
an answer like what was the address of
blah blah blah and as long as they
produce the right answer then they were
able to complete the task but in other
situations they have to self report that
they completed it and but yeah in this
case it was based on self-report and
here we're asking so yeah we were
wondering why is there a difference
between these completion rates and we
did a deeper dive into the feedback
questions that were asked and it turns
out that on YouTube there's not a way to
create an empty playlist and then add
songs to it the way you actually create
new playlist is you have to go to a song
and you have to then say add two new
playlist and that's how you create it
yeah listen instead of critically
listening to your songs to you I was
wondering did you try phrasing question
the other way and see if things never
changed how it was phrased when we tried
it but yeah I think it would have been
worse if we had phrased it the other way
because they would have implied that you
had to go first create a new playlist
yeah yes so we just happened to phrase
that this way but it could have been
yeah the results could have been worse I
guess this is actually a known problem
in YouTube in the sense I talked to
their one of their head designers and I
just checked like a few days ago and
they still haven't fixed it so okay so
the the last example I want to actually
show you as a comparison we did between
Macy's and best
and we had a simple task which was find
the address of the store closest to a
particular zip code so you're just kind
of looking for the near the nearest
let's say retail store and what I'm
showing you here is the golden trace
that let's say the designer would have
intended so you know you have to click
on the hamburger icon and there's a
flyout menu navigation and it takes six
interactions to get to the right answer
so here's a case where completion rate
is based on a right answer because we're
phrasing the task as a question
similarly on Best Buy if you were
performing the same task there's
actually two ways you can do it
there's a there way there's a way which
uses tap navigation which is just you
know on there on the the the first
screen or that you can go through a
search route so a priori we were
thinking that hey this is a shorter
interaction and there's actually two
ways to complete the task so you know
Best Buy should perform better and what
we actually found in practice was that
Macy's was easier for people and it's
interesting because I think five years
ago everyone was telling me don't use
hamburger menu icons they're hiding all
of the you know capabilities you should
just make it more clear to the user what
you can do on an app when you're on the
home screen but now people are just so
used to this design pattern that if you
don't use one you might end up confusing
users so it's kind of interesting how
you know these design trends might
change over time and I the reason I said
people actually found this use easier
was they actually self-reported it being
easier I think a lot of people on the
Best Buy got confused by the search
experience because you had to be in the
right search mode to actually search for
stores and not products and so we saw
users who are trying to search for store
locations in the product search search
bar so let's take a step back and talk
about what are the implications of the
system well we're you know giving a way
for people to test earlier in the design
process right because you don't have to
go out and build out all of these
different design alternatives you can
actually leverage existing apps and you
can run tests on them and when you are
designing your own flows you can kind of
take the things you've learned as best
practice from running your tests and use
that knowledge to design your own flows
it also gives you a way to do
comparative design testing at scale so
if you wanted to you know compare a Best
Buy up to a Macy's app right now the
only kind of service out there that you
can use is user testing comm where they
will actually video you know a user take
a screen video of a user using an app to
do different tasks and it's around 50
dollars a user and the reason it's
around 50 dollars a user is because
someone has to manually go through and
then annotate those videos and figure
out like what's happening in our case
because we're collecting kind of this
structured data about interaction it's
easier for us to automatically aggregate
this data and to surface
you know insights about it and then
finally the the thing that is
interesting about zipped I think is the
way you can combine different types of
quantitative and qualitative findings
and use that to inform each other you
know you can first find that there's a
problem and then you can say you know
why is that problem happening how can we
fix it so I think this is a this is a
testing form where you can both figure
out the how and or what and the why now
I I think there's one important thing
that is not yet exposed in this testing
interface and that is higher level
design semantics so all the design
descriptions we've collected are very
low level right I showed you a flow
visualization and
the reason we're able to do those is
because we've understood that two
screens are basically the same but what
we want to really understand is like
across apps when are you know two
screens are two floats basically the
same what are people doing search
interactions what are people doing
checkout interactions when are people
you know clicking on an article like we
need to understand those higher-level
semantics so kind of the next step in
this work is actually figuring out what
these design semantics are and also
being able to automatically identify
them in the traces so in order to
actually do this work we had to collect
data set big enough to where we could
actually use it to understand first of
all what are the most common UX UI
concepts in mobile apps and then second
you know can we build automatic methods
of detecting them so we release the data
set called Rico and it uses the same
capture technology as Erika and so
actually I would love if you guys if you
have the time later this week check this
out because we really are hoping more
people use this data set it provides
interaction traces for around 10,000
Android apps which means more than 72
thousand unique you eyes which is there
approximately 3 million UI elements and
so we use this data set to first
identify you know what should be a
lexicon of UX concepts and we coded 73
thousand potential icons and 130
thousand text buttons that were in this
data set and by potential icons I mean
images that are small and squarish that
appear in the in the UI hierarchy and we
use this to basically identify around a
hundred eighty concepts UX concepts and
if you're curious about the lexicon you
can also check it out at the URL on the
on that slide there are some interesting
patterns we found where
certain concepts or only usually
expressed as text so you can have things
like log in and subscribe you won't ever
find icons for these concepts similarly
you can have icons that are roughly
synonyms such as you know the pencil
type icon and the plus sign usually
signify an action like create and then
finally you can even have icon polysomes
which are interesting because these are
icons that can have slightly different
meaning depending on the context for
example the star I mean context could be
used for rating and in another context
can be used for favoriting or
bookmarking so we leverage this icon too
or we leverage this UX lexicon to then
create an automatic approach for
identifying design semantics and Android
apps and so we built this code and
vision based approach where we identify
twenty five you I component categories
197 text button concepts and around 99
icon classes so given a screen shot and
a UI hierarchy we can produce the
semantic version of that UI hierarchy
basically the tricky bit in this
pipeline was actually the icons
themselves because for a lot of the
other a lot of the other types of
components you can use basic code based
heuristics and they work pretty well for
Android apps but icons are again very
hard to differentiate just from images
and so we actually trained a
convolutional neural net that detects
between these 99 classes of icons and we
also use anomaly detection at the end of
the pipeline so we can differentiate
between icon classes as well as just
other content based things where it's
just a small image so I want to show you
some of the the classification results
it's cool because the average icons you
produce for the different classes really
show that they're you know people are
very consistent with the way they design
icons and that you think this is why the
you know machine learning algorithm is
able to learn something but you can see
that there's also some variation in each
class where you know people do take
their own stylistic you know there's
some room for style basically so once we
had kind of these element based
semantics what we wanted to see is can
we bootstrap higher-level semantics
based on these element level ones and so
for example can we understand screen
semantics was the question and what we
did was we trained a deep autoencoder to
basically capture semantics to see if we
can capture semantic properties over
screens and what we were able to do is
show that hey if you train an
autoencoder with those semantic versions
of the screenshots that we produced we
can actually learn a space where if you
do nearest neighbors nearest neighbors
queries in the space you get back
semantically similar screens so if you
query you as a login screen you will get
back other types of login screens from
other apps so these none of these
nearest neighbors are screens from the
same app just even though they look so
similar they're all from different apps
similarly we wanted to see if we could
do you know flow semantics so a flow is
just a sequence of screens where someone
is doing a particular semantic task and
the great thing was we were collecting
interaction data so if someone clicks on
a search icon right you kind of know
that they're about to start a search
flow so we kind of used that as our
heuristic and we went through the traces
and we basically use their design
semantic classifiers to identify
basically annotate different flows and
so we take the flows in the RICO dataset
here you can see that you know we can
identify where people were for example
doing filter because we've we can detect
all the places where they were clicking
on the filter icon you can check out
this database ODOT design that I'll just
make a plug for that URL I know there
are a lot of URLs I'll make a plug for
that URL because for for a limited time
Google or spots or it's work and we can
crawl all of these flows for free for
you guys so if you want you know us to
go crawl like five thousand more apps
just request them on the on the platform
and on that note I also want to come
back and say you know we've focused on
using Rico for specific types of
applications do you have a question okay
flow detection with usability testing to
kind of detect interesting design
patterns and then see if they're
actually good and then be able to say
that is a design pattern it works well
and it works well across several sizes
several house that is I mean that's
precisely why we want design semantics
right because right now we're doing kind
of these low-level comparisons and what
we'd love to do is say something like an
effective onboarding flow has five
screens so we need to be able to say on
board you know what is onboarding for
that and you're absolutely right like we
haven't done that stuff but that's yes
that's what we want to do but yeah like
I think the other thing is we're
obviously not going to be able to get to
all the applications you could you know
possibly work on with this data set and
so I again wanted to encourage people to
try looking at the Ricoh data set and
there are a lot of interesting projects
that have already emerged from this data
set at u-dub they used Rico to
understand and improve accessibility on
mobile apps at Google they're using it
to understand material design adoption I
know some folks are working on modeling
brand perception as well as training
generative models on this data set so
again this is my plug for the data set
hmm
okay so let's switch categories and talk
about how these data driven techniques
that I've been talking about in the
mobile design domain can also be applied
to something that seems very different
right which is fashion one of my main
motivations of you know for choosing
this as a domain is actually a consumer
one which is apparel is actually a three
trillion dollar global market I mean
actually dwarfs automotive industry
advertising consumer media and mobile
phones combined so I mean just like that
scale is pretty impressive
but you know the way we shop online
hasn't changed at all you know I'm sure
people are familiar with these screens
where you have to like choose what
you're looking for which could be pans
and then you have to like apparently
choose the the length of your pants and
what type of hem you want and like who
knows right and so you know the the gold
standard in the space in terms of user
interaction and user experience is
actually working with personal stylist
but not all of us can afford to do that
right so I recently there are have been
companies who are looking at how do we
democratize the personal stylist
experience with AI and stitch fix is one
of those companies so they have stylists
that use data-driven interfaces or
engines to actually make recommendations
to their users our question kind of in
the space is do you really need the
middleman right do you really need the
humans who are using the AI interfaces
can you give AI interfaces to the
consumers directly and if you do how can
you make it easy enough are
you know how can you make the user
experience good enough so that people
will be willing to do this the hard
thing in this space is actually the fact
that this space is just big so if you
look at the possible types of fashion
problems and the possible interventions
you could design it's just really huge
you might want feedback in an outfit you
might want help creating an outfit for
an event you might want seasonal item
recommendations and so forth people are
doing amazing work in computer vision
and machine learning to build all of
these different types of models like
ones for compatibility for image parsing
for detecting trends and at the same
time there's also all these data sources
out there every ecommerce you know site
is the data source basically in this
space as well as the other social
networks and media that are out there
and the editorial content so there's
just you know a lot going on in this
space and so we wanted a way to do need
finding in this space and understand a
scale kind of where should we focus so
to that end we built an experimentation
engine platform and it's kind of a fancy
way of saying Wizard of Oz chatbot but
I'll explain to you why I'm not saying
just Wizard of Oz chat pod so the goal
here is that this system is not the
product itself this is just a proxy
system and we're using it to Lauren so
we're using it to learn what are the
problems what are the important
interventions it's also going to help us
ID eight in terms of what are the right
types of solutions and then at the end
of the data also provides us a way to
deploy ml algorithms and being a tight
feedback loop with users and so these
are all the properties we want and I
know Wendy Jue has been working on
similar systems and she calls her need
finding machines so that's another word
you might hear out there but they're
they're very similar and
and so we built this facebook Messenger
bot initially that connects users to
one-on-one sessions with stylists and we
released this bot for three weeks our
stylists were Fashion Institute of
Technology students so they weren't
experts but they were they were still
more knowledgeable about fashion than
let's say the average consumer we
advertised on Facebook and Instagram and
we said hey are you looking for free
fashion advice thing this bot and
through that mechanism we collected 88
organic styling conversations with 73
unique users now there's actually a lot
of convergence in terms of the types of
problems people wanted solved definitely
the main problem everyone had was being
able to describe context for which they
were trying to dress so they were trying
to go to a wedding and they wanted to
you know something to wear to that they
were going to a conference next week
what should they wear for that what
should they wear for an interview so
these questions around context really
matter to people similarly people also
have a hard time with matching things so
if they're creating outfits they don't
know what goes with gray slacks and then
finally people actually came on and use
the bot to just do product search so
they would say I'm looking for a pair of
boots
now ecommerce sites already support this
type of interaction but it's interesting
that people would still come to the bot
for this because one could hypothesize
that people are just overwhelmed with
the set of choices that they're given
through search engines and they're never
provided kind of justification about
whether you know why one set of pair of
boots is better than the other pair of
boots we also studied the interaction
patterns that the stylists were using in
order to address these questions and so
the most interesting pattern to us was
the fact that they were using these
multimodal responses and by multimodal I
mean they use images
texts and so you people just never throw
up an image and say hey this is my
recommendation right people always give
an image and then explain why it kind of
fit the requirements the user was
looking for similarly they use the same
pattern when they're trying to help
users kind of refine their own problem
because if someone comes to the bottom
says I need shoes like there are a lot
of types of shoes out there right so you
need to then ask questions and show
examples to help users refine their
problem enough so you can actually help
them and so they use the same multimodal
pattern in both contexts and the word
code-switching is on that slide because
it's a very important one in this
context apparently when people talk
about fashion they use different
languages like experts use different
language from you know the average
consumer but the thing you have to
realize is that the expert still needs
to communicate in a way that the average
consumer can understand so even when
they have all of this expertise and
knowledge they have to you know kind of
translate between the two languages and
we saw this happen all the time so this
kind of like set up the set of design
requirements for basically if we wanted
to ever automate this like this is the
stuff we probably need to satisfy and so
this is kind of the first set of design
requirements we've arrived at and now
I'm going to work you through a deep
architecture that we design based on
these requirements first let's talk
about how this deals with compatibility
so there's a part of this architecture
where we've trained a visual
compatibility model from 70,000 fashion
outfits we actually got these outfits
from a social media site called poly
boar which unfortunately no longer is up
they took it down this summer but before
they took it down we were able to mine
this data
and we will it is available we will make
it available so you can also use it but
basically at a high level how we did
this was we wanted to satisfy that I
mean there there have been people who
have been modeling compatibility in
fashion but the insight we had was that
if you only trained one embedding in
this space
you are necessarily requiring things
that match a thing to be similar to each
other which is not always true so for
example two shoes that match the same
top are not necessarily similar to each
other things get matched for different
reasons and so the insight here for us
was let's train multiple embedding so
that you can allow for things to match
in different ways the other point we the
other requirement we cared about was it
being multimodal so what we did was we
took the visual embedding from the
compatibility model and we trained a
neural regressor basically to map the
visual embedding to 1300 text concepts
in fashion and we created that
vocabulary of text concepts as well so
that that wasn't something that was just
out there and standard and then finally
we also cared a lot about code switching
right because I said there's some
vocabulary that's used by experts and
some that's just so low-level are sorry
there's some language that average
consumers use and this this is really
interesting because it it's been studied
by fashion theorists for a while so
rolling Bart you know wrote in his the
language of fashion like what makes a
sweater smart is it the fact that it's
you know a sweater because it's silk
because it's white because it's square
neck like what are the attributes the
low-level features of fashion that makes
a sweater smart and so this is kind of
the problem or the this is the kind of
thing we want to learn or capture and
our first attempt at this was
training poly lingual topic models I
won't get into this in great detail but
what we were able to do is basically
Express every outfit as a distribution
over topics and each topic could be
expressed as a set of style words or
instead of low-level element words and
it powered interactions where people
could give a bunch of text describing
what they wanted and they could get item
recommendations for them so this is
something where someone describes you
know they're looking for something for
New York Fashion Week something for a
yoga retreat in Colorado something for a
tropical beach wedding so you can see
like it's getting important low level
attributes that might matter to these
high-level design requirements but the
thing we found was that you know the
inference here doesn't really work when
you have small documents and so in when
we looked at the chatbot data we saw
that consumers are not you know fond of
being verbose so this was not a very
scale you know this was not appropriate
for the types of interactions we wanted
to support the other thing was this
approach also doesn't let you really
capture the nuance of fashion where
people really want a grasp over you know
things that are very specific like
cowboy or nautical or something like
that so going back to our deep
architecture the way we're able to kind
of support more nuanced fashion is we
have a two-step training process and in
the first step we're actually you know
learning the distribution over all the
concepts the 13-hundred concept and in
the second step we're going to actually
use that first step as pre-training fix
those hidden layers and then train one
neuron per concept and this actually
really helps with the the terms that
have low frequency basically yeah yeah
I'm it's for learning the mapping
between visual features to text okay yes
and vice versa yeah the neural that will
regress to text yeah so it's mapping um
so the thing that this points out is
that if you add in step two for a lot of
concepts that are kind of on the tail
end you get higher activations as a
result whereas if you just stop at step
one you can see you never really you
know activate
so let me gonna show you some results of
this model just to give you a sense of
what are all the different types of
vocabulary we have so we have the type
vocabulary which is just like what kind
of item it is we have shapes and
silhouettes like you know maxi skinny
leg ankle
we have patterns like leopard print
floral plaid we have at the same time
though these really higher-level
concepts and styles like biker smart
bridal party beach and so forth and then
the cool part is that because we've kind
of categorized the vocabulary by these
these types of different words we can
kind of start constructing explanations
to recommendations and this is where all
of this was kind of like leading is that
we wanted ways to not just show people
images but to excellent
explain to them why they were being
shown and so we can say hey here are
evening gowns and the reason these are
evening gowns is because you know they
have a maxi or a MIDI silhouette they
have plunging asymmetric black lines and
a fluted are also fluted silhouette so
here we're able to use the other words
in the vocabulary to actually provide
justification for your recommendations
it also allows us to basically go
through and do other interactions that
could be useful like getting the you
know same look for less so the
and dresses you know usually cost more
than $1,000 but it's what there are
other brands that cost less than that
which have the same kind of bohemian
floral tiered ruffle look yes so the way
we're during the sentence as we as we
have some templates right now of
sentences and we're basically doing a
mad lib style generation where we say
insert you know material word insert
shape for it and you can and the reason
we actually chose this method is because
if you look at the copy on a lot of
websites for fashion it is very
templatized so future work is how do you
auto generate the whole sentence but
right now we can kind of fake it with
this and then the final example I'll
show you is one of my favorite ones
which is like we can use this method to
create capsule wardrobes which is a
trend in fashion these days as a way to
organize your closet so the goal of a
capsule wardrobe is to take a slice of
your wardrobe where you're minimizing
the number of items by maximizing the
number of outfits so you could create a
capsule for summer or a capsule for
winter a capsule for your vacation
things like that and so we can generate
these capsule wardrobes using that
compatibility portion of the model as
well and kind of give you sample outfits
and explain why they work so the stage
we're at right now is let's you know
we've built this model now we want to go
back and rerelease basically that bot
and see if we can take some of the
traffic or some of the questions and hit
it with the model and when we know we
don't have a way to answer that question
we would then send it to the stylist and
then use that again the goal is to get
into this iterative loop where we can
understand if these models are actually
you know providing value to the user now
in the last like two or three minutes
I want to tease my
the third domain I know I don't have a
ton of time but it's it's still a really
interesting one and it's around social
media and social networks and
recommendation systems curation has
become the central activity on social
networks because you know you see users
sharing and promoting content you know
network and everyone then benefits from
the network effects so definitely in
these systems you're incentivized to
identify who are top curators and I
won't get into the details of the
algorithm we came up with but I just
want to motivate how we kind of define
or frame this problem we want to find
people in the network who have
discerning tastes high activity and
timeliness and by timeliness I mean
people who have found things in the
network before they become kind of
socially popular right good curators are
first to identify the good stuff
similarly they have discerning tastes
because they you know they don't like
everything the only like the things that
are going to be good and we built this
algorithm for identifying curators in
social networks good curators and then
when we actually applied it to study
different networks what we found was
that it's interesting because on some
networks the people who are you know
adding content who are creating content
are now is the people who are the best
at curating content or who participate
in curating content so for example on
github
the the best tree the best creators are
usually like people like companies
whereas the best curators there are
individuals on github where they're not
adding code to the database but they're
just looking at how they can identify
code that will be useful to other people
in the future and then you know since we
can talk about identifying these
tastemakers we start looking at how do
we actually mind
taste itself from social networks and
you know honestly a lot of networks
where you're being served ads you're not
the signal you're giving the network is
actually doesn't contain your taste so
the thing that makes all of this really
hard is you actually have sparse user
data that you're working with our answer
to that was can we use a system where we
can incentivize people to leave more
clues about what they like so we built
in emoji based social media and I'll try
to do a demo this really quickly yeah
that worked okay and so yeah so for
example okay so the the way this works
it's called Oh Paco you can leave
reactions to places but at the most you
can use only five emoji so let's leave a
quick reaction to like Stanford or or we
can even be fancy and say gates okay so
I'm leaving a reaction to the gates
computer science building I'm giving a
talk hopefully I'll be meeting people
and I am you know starstruck and I'm
either going to share this to Facebook
because why not and I'm posting so okay
so that took me a few seconds okay a few
seconds but now I just communicated that
hey you know I go hang out and give
talks at you know good universities
that's part of my you know taste profile
now suppose I was in the area and I was
following some people right who yeah so
these are like reactions people have
been leaving around Stanford so someone
got their Lexus fixed cool okay but
suppose I really need coffee so I can
actually then search for coffee and
let's see if this is somebody and IKEA
okay maybe I don't trust that but
suppose I want to do coffee and work
okay this person was also working
all right here so okay oh I guess five
months ago is that bluebottle
doing work anyway um so that's that's
kind of how you can use OPA Co are you
know we're at a thousand users about a
hundred monthly active users we most of
the users are in urbana-champaign but
you know that's why I'm demoing it here
so we can build up the user base here
but honestly the goal is to see is if
emoji can be a good way to both capture
you know get incentivize people to leave
these lightweight reactions but then
turn around and like actually understand
your taste and provide you useful
recommendations so that's that's a
long-term goal we're still at the let's
grow the user base part okay so you know
looking forward there's kind of just
three things I want to leave you with
one is I've been talking a lot about
design datasets and there's an important
distinction between design datasets and
I think just other datasets out there
which is that you know on images for
example if there's a red panda in the
photo like it's always going to be a red
panda in the photo but in design what
you are trying to capture it changes
over time so like trends change what you
know modern means in design changes all
the time but even the language itself
you know changes over time in fashion
and mobile apps everything the other
thing I want you guys to think about is
how do you take these different design
processes one is like in product design
and one is in let's say machine learning
design how do you actually put them
together to have a effective data-driven
design thinking process I think we have
it I think that's a very open problem
still and and then the last thing is you
know I talked about how important it was
to correlate design choices to
performance then step after that is
predicting performance so given a design
saying how good it is and then once you
know what is kind of
good or what those preferred outcomes
are you can use that data to actually
start generating and like just to tease
you guys you know imagine these
interactions where a designer might
start designing a login you know screen
puts down a logo and I'll log in with
Facebook button but then you know this
tool can actually suggest all these
different ways to resize those elements
on the screen and add the missing
element so really think of it as a way
to autocomplete design I think that's
kind of the the future of where all of
this stuff is heading and hopefully it's
an exciting future
um this is my data-driven design group
and I want to thank you all for your
time and happy to take any questions